[Music]
oh my gosh
i learned about myself
i you know what i i florence is so
self-possessed
i was not that self-possessed i don't
think i
i think actually i realized wow i have a
lot of work to do
on myself when i worked with
florence i was like she's got such a
healthy ego
and is like in her skin it's one of the
things about florence that i think the
audience also responds to in this
character she's very much
what you see is what you get she's
herself
like all the whatever all the
different sides of her there are out
there and uh
you know she's not judging herself and i
i love that about her and i would love
to be more like that
what are the steps i take you know it's
not more about learning about myself it
was more
that i was just i think i'd never been
in quite a position like that where i
could watch a woman
as successful as she was be such a boss
and
and what that required to be and what
requires from you to be such a boss and
i think something i really loved
you know she produced this film she's
been working on it for a really long
time she's starring in it
um it was awesome to see this woman take
charge of the set
and say no and pause at times to discuss
things that need to be discussed and
not be pressured into filming something
just because we're running out of time
and i think that's something that maybe
definitely is a woman you learn a lot
later on and it was just really lovely
to see
this like legend just basically run this
set
um and just to take notes from that and
watch that and see that it's
that's awesome and people respected that
and there's a reason why she is so
fantastic
and it's because of that so yeah i think
my version was just like wow i've got a
lot of taking notes to do
and what person to do that from
[Music]
well i do think the film is inherently
female be partly because of
kate shortland directing it it
definitely has
um you know it sheds light on
it sheds light on a
you know um on an imbalance i think that
uh women feel like inherently
because of how our society is
has been forever thousands and thousands
of years
and um you know the movie is
about the subjugation of women and
um you know the trauma that uh
we have to help one another out of
um and you know it's a film about women
lifting one another up
so that they may thrive i mean i i don't
think that you
can really take that out of
this film because it is it isn't been an
ingredient there
um you know and it's it's about time too
i kind of don't want it to not be not
there
um i don't know if i said that right uh
because it's
it's important you know it's an
important
piece of all this it's an important
piece of moving away
from having that need to be a part of it
too
don't know
isn't that sad
you go bad scarlett i need to do some
deep thinking
oh my gosh yeah i think you have to be
all
as a woman you have to be all the time
um
you know because we are under
minded and underserved and under
appreciated and underpaid and you have
to be your own ally
um you know my mom instilled that in me
for when i was
really really young um because of course
she'd experienced it even more severely
than i
than i did and you know equal pay is a
huge part of
of that fight um when i even when i was
a teenager in the industry or a young
woman i should say my mom
you know would have those conversations
like what
why is she not getting you know that it
had never had anything to do
and there was always these these like
these little key terms like um you know
bank ability
and you know box office draw and those
are all
uh way those are all terms that are
basically masquerading
as sexism never had anything to do with
those things and if there ever was
it was also part of the systemic issue
that you know a woman could not have
be as bankable or have a boxing box
office straw um
it was it's it was and my mom refused
that
and instilled in me no you have to fight
that
you know don't see you know you're you
are you're desirable
because of your work and that's you know
that's where your value is it's in your
talent and and uh has nothing to do with
your gender and don't let anybody make
you feel that way
um so i think it's it really you know
it's a constant fight i'm still fighting
that damn fight we all are